welcome young one come in in the
soothsayer reveal to you a mystical
bounty of new and exciting video games
now I'm sure you all out there already
know about these these titan falls ended
and wash dogs but there's so much more
to discover using my all-seeing
all-powerful powers of divination i
shall reveal to you about dear
lesser-known but just as awesome games
to put on your radar as well as
absolutely predict the likelihood these
games will actually see the light of day
come along young one and prepare to be
amazed crypt of the necrodancer crypt of
the necrodancer is here to drop the beat
pump up the jams and otherwise raise the
roof this rhythm based roguelike demands
who let the music take control and move
with the beat the game's patented beat
detection algorithm let you jam out and
explore procedurally generated dungeons
based on your own songs plus it's the
only game in this set designed for ddr
pad chance of release eighty-one percent
this scapegoat to the puzzle platformer
escape goat is getting a sequel but
don't worry if you miss the original
with hand illustrated goat graphics
handcrafted go puzzles and a hand
composed goat soundtrack escape till two
mixes magical barnyard animals and
mind-bending puzzles in equal measure
and should you best the games challenges
a built-in level editor will be included
so you can try your own hand at puzzle
creation possibility of release
seventy-seven percent lead hog danger
adventure dueling all these things are
synonymous with facing and if you think
I'm wrong then you've obviously never
been to a sword fight new dog is also
filled with dangerous dueling adventures
played out across a 2d plane as two
duelists danced across the battlefield
searching for a break in the others
defenses the game's lightning fast speed
likens it to a tightly woven ball of
energy that only relents when one player
saber inches the other players torso
hand even in the respite is oh so
fleeting odds of relief
ninety-nine percent seriously it comes
out January 13 I'm betting it right now
Cheers punk oh yes jazz park just Punk'd
is a game about dumb well it's a game
about life and you know what I don't
even know throwing popcorn hitting
piñatas no wait it's an adventure a
first-person adventure brought to life
with an offbeat style and sense of humor
on its own set in an extremely alternate
universe version of the late 20th
century jazzpunk charges you were
committing corporate espionage exploring
its absurdist cold war-era world and
utilizing a wide assortment of tools to
generally harass the unsuspecting public
odds of release 63.3 for repeating of
course quadrilateral cowboy
quadrilateral cowboy is shaping up to be
an engrossing cowboy simulator only
instead of a cowboy you're more of a
computer hacker man instead of a gun you
have more of a laptop and instead of a
horse you have a motorcycle you know
what let's not sweat the details this
game is one of corporate intrigue and
computer hacking in a bygone era of tape
decks and CRT monitors armed with your
newfangled hacking device your breach
bypassing backdoor your way through the
finest security systems of the last
century possibility of release 56k hyper
light drifter a game that won the hearts
of thousands on Kickstarter hyper light
drifter is a gorgeous 2d action RPG
armed with incredibly detailed pixel art
Diablo s action and a stunning
soundtrack by masterful disaster piece
as a drifter a collector of lost
knowledge and technology you will delve
deep into the forgotten corners of the
world in search of the unknown there's a
lot to love and hyper light drifter and
it simply can't get here fast enough
seriously it's awesome possibility of
release forty-seven percent
brain world a fast-paced sneaking
platformer where you attack prey while
avoid getting killed yourself rain world
puts you in control of Mayor what is it
a white ghost ferret creature possibly a
slug cat anyway by playing solo or with
friends cooperatively players will
navigate maze-like environments while
hunting lesser creatures and avoiding
becoming lunch with a lizard-like
creatures who dominate this virtual
ecosystem and as with a scapegoat to a
level editor is also in the works so all
you would be level designers can flex
your creative muscles divination says
negative Georgie 8% hope you weren't
looking forward to it video the universe
a delight for the senses radio the
universe blends classic Zelda style
action and dark science fiction to form
a distinct haunting style that's hard to
forget utilizing a sheep short-range
teleport and other abilities you will
help guide an unnamed heroin through a
Samba trapped filled labyrinth but be
mindful because as the Kickstarter page
notes players who died in game die in
real life divination says your day oh
wait wait wait you weren't supposed to
see that the iconoclasts robin is a
badass mechanic who alters her
surroundings then smashes foes at our
trusty rich the iconoclasts is a badass
action platformer that has a wonderfully
vibrant world and needs to be on our
computer right now the two were made for
each other then we all want to believe
that they'll come out this year but only
time will tell well time and divination
likelihood of release 08 percent it's
not happening routine with a plot
straight out of a relief scott sci fi
film routine tasks players with
investigating the disappearance of
everyone on a lunar research station
the anxiety of your search is
underscored by a throwback to the bleeps
and bloops of clunky 1980s technology I
mean if bioshock's Columbia can have
turn-of-the-century steam powered gizmos
in the sky there's no reason we can't
have a floppy disk on the moon am i
right of course I'm right divination
says ask again later oh it always does
this at the end you know what forget it
we're done we're done and there you have
it young one go forth in a way to this
rich bounty of gaming goodness as for me
I must travel to the future and confirm
just how right I am soothsayer out